i don't believe that you can find love i
think you have to build love if it's
something you have to build a
relationship yeah you cannot love
someone you haven't connected or build
time together yeah the only way to
measure
uh a relationship is going up and down
with someone so stop saying guys that
i understand you but stop saying you
love
hot women you don't love them yeah you
want to have sex with them you sex with
you you preach
you
love you you find them super attractive
but you don't love them brother as soon
as you're with them
and and another thing is that at some
point anyone attractive is going to
become a like dog food
this happens with everyone what do you
mean by that this is gonna be hard for
me to explain especially because you
just
compare you to dog food yeah
well but that's what i do called i know
that's what i do i know okay uh
but i love what you said by the way just
to set you up you said you don't find
love you build love yeah you build love
you have to go and you guys have built
love you and you yeah up and down that's
why you're we're not jealous there's a
saying in spanish about the blue prince
i don't know if in english it works the
same way but they always told me like
you don't find a blue prince you find a
prince and you paint it blue
so you don't you don't find the perfect
man prince charming i think it's oh
prince charming yeah but it doesn't work
the same because there's no color
there's no color but you don't you can't
find the perfect guy you you find that
that is willing to change and you have
to be willing to change and together you
change you build something inside you
build that woman that you want you build
it you build her he'll she builds you
brother she'll build you if you find
someone and you're like this is who i am
and this is who i am and i feel proud
and this is me i'm gonna change and i'm
not gonna change you're never gonna find
anyone you have to be willing to change
which doesn't mean you're gonna have to
change your values or you don't wanna
change you're gonna are in your core
but you have to be willing to change for
someone else and be better and evolve
let me explain the dog food thing
because i'm going to do this it's on
internet
okay
the brain
uh works
like this with everything a dog you give
dog food and so you give them a mistake
it's like oh finally something different
it's the same for us for us man you're
gonna marry a super hot woman that you
think you love and at some point she's
gonna become
for the brain the same the same
food every day
so you're gonna want new food new love
new women or new men whatever it happens
with women a lot actually thing happens
most with women
and actually do you think it happens
more with women than what
that
i don't know
they start saying this thing that i
don't believe anyone understands people
say i stop loving you
and you don't stop loving someone you
just stop admiring them
at my admiration is the link
for someone to want to be with someone
that's the link but you don't you still
love them you still love the the father
of your
of your child you just no admiration
there's nothing to fight for
i still love your brother we're you know
we have a kid together up and down with
that's love but there's no admiration
why am i fighting for so
much monotony
that's what i'm talking about
monogamy
well you know you know there's a famous
phrase that that
that they say that men say
you've heard this before honestly i
don't want to upset anybody
show me a hot chick
and i'll show you a guy who's tired of
[ __ ] her yes you've heard this before
monogamy okay exactly he's having
a steak every single day and he's just
like you know what i just want some
[ __ ] french fries one night
okay
but that
dynamics yeah talk to you why do you
think people like going to buffets
they're like i can get this and this and
then
also this doesn't mean you have to go
around and [ __ ] other people okay we're
not talking about operations so what's
the solution the solution is dynamics
dynamic do different things go don't
have sex in the same bed every night go
to hotels
take a vacation
watch porn together get a toy like i
don't know watch a movie a different
movie together there's so many
ideas don't be monotonous don't exactly
change
i don't like to see eh this is gonna be
hard for me to i'm gonna say something
private okay sorry sorry but i like i
don't like
consent can i say
one thing i would say i love that you
call the girls brother this is your
brother
i don't like to see christina naked
if we're not gonna have sex
i love to see her around her booty or i
love it she knows it even when she's
going to work out but if you see her
naked every day the brain mm-hmm
i don't completely agree with that it's
very accurate right now yeah so we try
to keep and we have had issues health
issues that had you know yes make us be
in very uncomfortable positions and we
have to kind of like block that part but
yeah we try to keep the
also because we work together we're
together 24 7 like all the time so we
try to have private time so we kind of
miss each other it doesn't happen a lot
but we try yeah and yeah like we don't
we don't go to the bathroom with the
door open or i mean i do but i
don't i told her like dude close the
door bro close the door we try to keep
some privacy so we don't become
roommates
yeah that's the biggest problem in
relationships is that you always hear it
felt like we were becoming roommates we
felt like no you know
no you don't want to be a [ __ ]
roommate no no okay what were you going
to say about no it's just like
that's why i connect with them so much
because even though we do different
things with our life the way we see life
is very similar and i i couldn't agree
more with you it's exactly like that
keep things interesting and never stop
growing never stop growing like if you
keep on evolving and whatever is that
you want to do personally that's always
going to be attractive that always
something that people are going to seek
for because you become a new person all
the time so it's part of the evolution
the company interesting yeah yeah like
we started he was a photographer and i'm
a makeup artist and then now he's
studying he's becoming more a therapist
i became a health coach and now we're
doing different things so we he we both
used to be really fat and now we're both
like very strong and fit yeah i saw a
picture of you being fat i saw i was
like where is this guy we were fast you
lost 100 pounds 100 pounds oh my
goodness so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire sauce cast
click right here
[Music]